Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lobst, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Michael Wilson. He's a
professor in the Department of Ecology, Evolution and Behavior
at the University of Minnesota. And today we're going
to talk about his work on the chimpanzees at
Gombe National Park in Tanzania, animal personality, how apes
are impacted by human activity. And some other related
topics. So, Doctor Wilson, welcome to the show. It's
a huge pleasure to everyone.
Thank you very much, Ricardo. It's a huge pleasure
to be here.
So let's start, I mean, to introduce the audience
to your work. Tell us about the chimpanzees at
Gombe National Park in Tanzania. I mean, what led
you to study chimpanzees there specifically, and what have
you studied among them in terms of their behavior,
ecology, and so on?
So the chimpanzees of Gombe National Park are the
chimpanzees that Jane Goodall began studying in 1960. So
they are the subjects of the first long-term study
of chimpanzees in the wild and the longest running
study of chimpanzees. And so I've been hearing about
these chimpanzees since a child, you know, I, you
know, they've been studied longer than I've been alive,
and, uh, so we know. An incredible amount about
their lives in, in great detail. I came to
the study of chimpanzees uh through A broad interest
in evolution and human origins and how we came
to be the sorts of animal that we are.
And my first work doing Uh, studies in the
wild of primates, uh, focused on baboons. I worked
for Gene Altman, uh, as a data manager for
the Ambaceli Baboon Project, which is based in Ambaseli,
Kenya. And I spent about 10 months in, uh,
Impala Research camp in Laikipia, Kenya, studying olive baboons,
and which was terrific. I, the baboons are super
interesting and Being on the ground with baboons, you're
following them around on foot in An area that
still had elephants and lions and leopards and hyenas
and all of these animals was really powerful in
terms of understanding what life must have been like
for our early ancestors, but it, it also made
me really wonder, well, what about species that are
more closely related to us? Baboons are interesting, they
have fascinating social lives, but would we not learn
more? Uh, BY studying our closest living relatives, and
so that led me to, uh, looking into chimpanzees
as, as a research, uh, focus. And so that's
what I ended up doing for as a graduate
student at Harvard University. I, uh, worked in Kibali
National Park in western Uganda studying chimpanzees there. And
then when I went on to do postdoctoral work,
uh, with Ampezzi at the University of Minnesota, I.
That's when I began working at Gombe, and the
thing that really led me to, to work at,
uh, at Gombe with Ann was that. I had
become interested in this question of intergroup relations and
the Kanawara chimpanzee community that uh I had been
studying for my doctoral research that uh in a
project that Richard Wrangham leads, they didn't have any
neighbors that were habituated, meaning that you could uh
follow them as well as the, the main research
community. So when Interactions occurred between groups. We, we
only had information from one side of the interaction.
And so I, uh, I knew that at Gombe,
the, there were two study groups that were habituated
and so there was information from both sides of
the interaction there and, uh, and Pewy had funds
to support someone studying those interactions. So that's, that's
what led me to Gombe. Mhm.
Uh, AND I mean, what aspects of, uh, chimpanzee
behavior and how ecology specifically impacts their behavior, influences
their behavior are you most interested in?
So I'm interested in many different aspects of their
behavior, but what I've focused on, uh, in my
research at Gombe has been. Aggression and the things
that cause chimpanzees to behave violently um towards each
other, both within groups and between groups and the
relationship to ecology is that the. The environment in
which an animal lives, the foods that they eat,
the resources that they need to survive, have a
profound impact on social behavior. Are they able to
afford to live in groups given the foods that
they eat? Uh, CAN they live in big groups
or small groups? Chimpanzees have an unusual society, uh.
Instead of traveling always in a coherent group like
gorillas do or olive baboons, they have a fission
fusion social structure in which individuals come together sometimes
in big parties and disperse into small parties, and
this. It is also similar to our own social
structure. We, we're always, you know, coming and going,
joining into larger parties and breaking up into smaller
parties. So there's, there's an intriguing similarity with what
humans do there. And this also seems to be,
well, it's very much related to food. So when
food is abundant. They can afford to travel in
larger parties and keep themselves fed because chimpanzees, like
most primates, spend most of the day looking for
food. They need to feed themselves to grow and
produce offspring and survive, and so they need food
and they also compete over access to food, both
with other members of their group and between groups,
and The competition to control a particular patch of
land, a territory, uh, seems to be, well, for
one, it's a big driver of intergroup aggression in
chimpanzees, because they need to defend their particular patch
of land in order to ensure a food supply
for themselves and their, their mates and their offspring.
And, uh, Also the food. Uh, THE variation in
the food supply means that they're not always able
to travel in a big party, and this means
that individuals during some seasons are scattered and alone,
and that seems to play a big role in
their vulnerability to intergroup violence. Mhm.
Yeah, because, uh, I mean, it's interesting, of course,
I don't know exactly the details. I mean, I
couldn't tell. I, I don't have memorized in what
ways, for example, the kind of environment, if it's
more mountainous, if it's more of a forest environment
or something like that, and the kinds of, uh,
let's say food resources. That different chimpanzee groups have
access to in what ways that specific, those factors
specifically influence their environment and make different groups behave
in different ways, but certainly ecological factors play a
big role there, right, because I would imagine that
chimpanzee groups across Africa. For example, would have, uh,
because they are part of the same species, some
commonalities, but because they live in different ecological contexts,
there's also lots of variability in terms of their
sociality. I mean, am I correct here or not?
Yes, that's right. There's a tremendous amount of variation
among chimpanzee populations in lots of different. Aspects they,
they differ in terms of their tool use. For
example, uh, at Gombe, they use, um, sticks to
fish for termites and ants, and, uh, they, but
they don't use stone tools, whereas in West Africa,
there are chimpanzees that use stone tools to break
open nuts, and chimpanzees have. Have nuts at Gombe
and they have stones, but they have never figured
out stone tools, so they're. There's an interesting combination
of both ecological factors that can influence behavior, but
also these cultural factors like the ability to use
stone tools versus the ability to termite fish that
seem to Very true in a way that's not
directly related in an obvious way to us, at
least to ecology. And It seems likely that these
ecological uh variables affect social behavior, but to be
honest, we don't have a very good understanding of
it. We, you know, I think we're still in
early stages of how do we even characterize what
is in the habitat that is causing variation. So
we can see that chimpanzees at You know, some
sites have very high rates of intergroup killing, uh,
chimpanzees at other sites have very high rates of
within-group violence. Some chimpanzee communities have high rates of,
of violence against infants versus others have high rates
of violence against adults. And the factors that. Cause
that variation, I, I think we're still in pretty
early stages of, of trying to figure them out.
Right? Uh, SO I know that you've studied, uh,
particularly animal personality at Gombe. So, uh, what do
we know about personality in chimpanzees, and I mean,
uh, do you, When you study animal personality, do
you approach it in a similar way that we
approach personality in humans, or are there differences?
So personality is one of the things that Has
distinguished research at at Gombe, I think from the
very beginning and that Jane Goodall was immediately struck
by how different individual chimpanzees were. And at that
time, The The kind of um reigning view in
animal behavior was to focus on things that we
could quantify scientifically, and there was a great concern
with Anthropomorphizing or projecting our own traits onto animals
and So, animal behavior researchers at the time were
generally extremely wary of, of using terms like personality
because that just seems too, too fuzzy and non-scientific
and uh. So that was something that uh Jane
felt she, she faced resistance to in, in among
her scientific colleagues, but to her it was obvious
that the chimpanzees just differed uh from one another.
They had. Different tendencies to do things, and she,
you know, she learned the individuals very quickly, and
she kept character files where she kept track of
the individual life history and the things that they
did, and, and she maintained this interest in Individual
distinctiveness throughout her study, uh, both, you know, from
the very beginning. And In recent decades, researchers have
worked to develop ways to Try to assess personality
in a more, you know, in a kind of
rigorous scientific way, which is not easy. It's, it's
really hard to, uh, to capture this. It's something
that, you know, intuitively, it's obvious. If you're watching
chimpanzees, they're not all the same, they do things
differently, but how do you How do you capture
that? And there, there are two different approaches to
doing that, and one is to take the data
that we're already collecting. Quantitatively and You know Put
those numbers together. You know, to look at Different
individuals, how often are they aggressive, how often, uh,
you know, what, what is their mating success like?
What are they, uh, uh, how often do they
engage in violence? And, um, so these are things
that we collect data on and, and look at.
And There, there is also another approach that focuses
on trying to capture people's intuitions about the animals,
and Alex Weiss, who's a colleague of ours who
is a psychologist and has focused on studying chimpanzee
personality in captivity. He came to Gombe and uh
we worked uh with our Tanzanian colleagues to develop
a, a questionnaire translated from English into Swahili that's
based on the questionnaires that people have been using
to characterize personality and in captivity and translated that
to Swahili and interviewed. Many of the long-term Tanzanian
researchers who've been working with the project for decades
and, and have got to know each individual chimpanzee
very well. And so, They answered those kind of
detailed questionnaires, and then uh Alex performed some fancy
statistics to try to capture different personality dimensions and
uh Overall, that, that project led to uh You
know, finding that some of the personality traits that
have been documented in captive chimpanzees are also present
in wild chimpanzees, and they, they vary a lot.
And uh we've worked with um our, our colleague
Joseph Feldblum at Duke University to, to see if
those personality traits relate to anything else that we
can quantify, you know, to see if these, uh,
are, are these really accurate reflections of chimpanzee. Behavior
and, and do they matter in real life and,
and what, uh, what we found was that there
is a, a positive correlation between the personality trait
of dominant. With reproductive success. So, and, and this
is a personality trait that's scored independently of knowing
their dominance ranks. So it's uh it's a separate
thing even though it has almost the same name.
And uh so that, that finding and also I
think chimpanzees that were low on the trait conscientiousness
also had high reproductive success. So, so that suggests
that this, this personality. Our, our, our measures of
personality are capturing something that's real about chimpanzees and
that matters in terms of, uh, reproductive success and
hence natural selection in the long term.
Yeah, I would imagine that it's a bit bothersome
that we cannot ask chimpanzees to just answer personality
questionnaires like we do with humans, but on the
other hand, since questionnaires are basically self a form
of self-reporting, I mean, it's Actually, perhaps in a
way more reliable to just look at their behavior
and identify their personality traits through that because I
mean, humans can, uh, lie.
Absolutely, and, and I personally really hate filling out
personality questionnaires myself because I, I, I always feel
like I'm lying on them because I have an
idea of what I, I know would be. An
answer that people would like to hear and so
I'm tempted to give. An answer that, you know,
I, I, you know, that would be admirable, I
guess. I don't know, you know, it's, it's, I,
I find those very difficult to, uh, to fill
out. So, so I'm skeptical of them.
Uh, SO, uh, I have now a question, and,
and this also, I guess, can relate at least
to some extent to what we've already talked about
when it comes to how ecological circumstances or conditions
impact, uh, behavior. Uh, IN what ways have apes
been impacted, uh, apes more generally, not just chimpanzees
in this case, been impacted by human activity?
So Broadly speaking, apes have been enormously impacted by
human activity in much the same ways that every
other. Living thing on the planet has been impacted
by human activity. Uh, HUMANS, uh, have taken over
the world and, and undertaken this enormous effort to
convert the planet into, uh, you know, human-friendly feeding
habitat, and So, what that has meant has been
an enormous conversion of habitat from forest to farmlands
and towns and villages and cities, and also the
direct extraction of wild animals for for food and
uh for the pet trade, for entertainment, uh, for
biomedical experimentation. So, There are a lot fewer non-human
apes on the planet now than there were even
a couple of decades ago, and Many places that
used to have apes no longer do. Uh, SOME
of the smaller apes like gibbons, uh, used to
be widespread in, uh, China, for example, and now,
uh, very few gibbons remain at all, uh, in
that country. Orangutans also used to be found on
mainland Southeast Asia, uh, and now they only exist
on, uh, two islands in Indonesia where they are
in extreme peril, and, uh, pretty much everywhere. Uh,
THE story is the same, is that, uh, apes
are being, uh, Hunted and uh deprived of their
homes.
Right, but do they exhibit flexibility or are they
able to be flexible in terms of the way
they respond to human activity? And in a related
question, I would also like to ask you, I
mean, we have to be careful when studying. In
this case, primate behavior or ape behavior in certain
ecological circumstances and the kinds of conclusions we derived
from that because we have to take into account
that sometimes they Are change their behavior in response
to human activity, right? And so maybe, I don't
know, in certain, uh, circumstances, they might be, uh,
more violent than usual, but that's because of, uh,
uh, because of them responding to, uh, human activity
and how it impacts their ecology.
Right, so apes are extremely flexible and adaptable, and
they They can change their behavior in various ways
to respond to, for example, the threat that humans
pose. Um, ONE thing that I studied in, in
my own research as a graduate student involved, uh,
well, I was interested in this question of are
apes, are chimpanzees. Quiet when they conduct boundary patrols
of their territories, and this was something that everyone
asserted that they go on a boundary patrol and
they're quiet and I wanted to quantify that, and
so I collected data on their vocal behavior throughout
their range. And one thing that I found that
I hadn't really been planning to look for initially,
but this came up. As an opportunity based on
what I observed was that. On one side of
the park where. The chimpanzee community bordered directly with
with villages where people planted crops. The chimpanzees would
sometimes leave the forest and go into people's villages,
or not into their villages per se, but their
croplands and raid crops. And they would push over
banana plants and open up the, uh, the stems
to get the pith that they really like, uh,
and they ate various other foods from people's crops.
And very often when chimpanzees arrive at a rich
food source, they give loud calls. They give pant
hoots and rough grunts and Other causes that are
associated with finding a lot of food. But when
they would go into these croplands that had lots
of food, they generally stayed very quiet. And what
I think was happening is that they, they knew
that there was a threat of being exposed if
they made a lot of noise in these fields,
and so they stayed quiet while they were. Ripping
up people's gardens and so that's an example of
flexibility and and how human behavior impacts ape behavior,
uh, non-human ape behavior. And there are Other ways
in which things that we do can impact their
behavior, for example, when When Jane Goodall was first
working at Gombe, she learned in the first years
of her study that chimpanzees were very attracted to
the food that she had in her camp, and
they came to steal bananas from her, from her
camp. And so she started using bananas to attract
chimpanzees to a central area where she could observe
them and film them and photograph them more easily.
And so for the first years of the study,
Well, the very first years of the study, she
had focused on following chimps in the wild, but
once she saw how difficult that was and how
easy it was to observe them when they came
to eat the bananas. She shifted the emphasis of
her work and for much of the mid to
later 1960s, focused her, her work on observing chimpanzees
in that banana feeding area, which was A way
for her to See in rich detail these things
like individual differences and personalities, and she was able
to document all of that sort of behavior, but
it also had an impact on the chimp behavior
in lots of ways because it attracted chimps to
a central resource. It also attracted baboons to a
central resource, and it changed behaviors in a number
of ways that Richard Rangha I documented in a
1974 paper where he found that. The rates of
aggression around the banana feeding station or in the
banana feeding area were much higher than in the
forest, and Richard was, was part of the You
know, the kind of early pioneers of researchers at
Gombe who were focused on, well, let's follow the
chimpanzees away from the banana feeding station and into
the forest and collect data. Uh, HE was one
of several people who really focused on that and
shifted the research back towards focusing on, on the
wild behavior. And when it became clear that banana
feeding was having that impact, that was one of
the things that, uh, Convinced, uh, Jane Goodall to
reduce the intensity of banana feeding. Eventually, we stopped
it entirely, although that took some time. Um. So
it's, it's clear that banana feeding had an impact
on, on their behavior and then in the In
the mid 1970s. Researchers at Gombe started seeing inter-community
killings, and the, the main study community. Split into
two, which Jane called the Casaquila community to the
north and the Kahama community to the south, and
Males from the Casaquila community attacked and killed a
number of individuals, uh, mainly males, but also one
female from the Cahama community, eventually leading to the
extinction of the Cahama community. And these observations surprised.
Pretty much everyone in the chimp research community. And
Led to both lots of interest in what chimpanzees
might tell us about the origin of this warlike
behavior and how it relates to warfare in humans
and also led some critics to say, well, look,
it's because Jane was feeding them bananas, um, that
that this caused their behavior to change and It
is the case that the banana feeding increased rates
of aggression, and it's also possible that the banana
feeding had other impacts because as it concentrated the
casaquila community into the center of their range. They
were able to um Get lots of food without
doing the hard work of traveling across more of
their range and defending that and. So other chimpanzees,
probably what we, what we speculate, and this is
um And um Something that we've, we've published on,
but, uh, we don't have much data on this.
It's speculative that the, the other chimp communities kind
of moved in to the the vacuum that Casaquila
had left by not patrolling those areas. And then
when the banana feeding decreased, now you have increased
competition for uh land within the park. And at
the same time, talking about human influences. This coincided
with an increase in rates of deforestation outside the
park, so chimpanzees that had been living in forests
outside the park now had less forest to live
in, and so they may have contracted their ranges
to within the boundaries of the park today. It's,
it's impossible to know. Now, what exactly went into
all of these things, but, um, you know, because
we, we don't have data on these unhabituated chimpanzees
and we don't really know what their movements were,
were like. But the The idea, uh. Has You
know Persisted that somehow Gombe is unnatural because of
the banana feeding, because of these, these other impacts,
and therefore, well, if, if there's violence at Gombe,
it's because of something that, that humans have, have
done. And, and some critics of chimpanzee violent research
have really run with us. Brian Ferguson recently published
a whole book on this topic in which he
argues that pretty much all chimpanzee violence somehow relates
to human impacts, and I think that's overstating the
case quite a bit because If, well, it, it
raises multiple questions. For one, We see chimpanzee violence
at lots of study sites, not just at Gombe,
and it's not just at the sites that are
most impacted by human activities, uh, the, uh, The
chimpanzee community with probably more documented killings than any
other is the Ngogo community at the heart of
Kibali National Park, which is very far from the
forest edge and, and probably is, is one of
the less impacted communities uh in terms of human
impacts. Although Brian Ferguson comes up with a story
to explain somehow how Ngogo chimpanzees are really heavily
impacted by humans, uh, But I, I think I
it's You know, when, when you can Like even
within Kibale National Park, the Kanuwara chimpanzees that I
studied for my dissertation research are much more heavily
impacted by humans than the Ngogo chimpanzees at the
center of the park, and yet their, their rate
of killing is, is much lower. So I don't
think that's a convincing argument. And then there's also
The fact that many other primate species have been
observed under a broad range of human impacts, and
they don't kill each other, uh, or at least
not nearly at the, the high rate that chimpanzees
do. Uh, BONOBOS, very few killings have been observed
for bonobos, and they're, uh, very similar to chimpanzees
and just as closely related to us as chimpanzees
are, uh, and they live in places that are
impacted to varying degrees by humans. So why? Or
the human impacts make chimpanzees kill but not bonobos.
Right, and I, I mean, I actually want to
ask you more about that and it's interesting that
you also touched on the point regarding warfare because
of course we know that one of the sources,
it's not the only source of course, but one
of the sources. OF evidence that people who argue,
uh, scientists, anthropologists, so and so on, who argue
that uh warfare is uh an evolved adaptation in
humans, uh, uh, resort to is actually chimpanzee violence.
So, uh, I mean, what, what, what can we
tell, uh, from studying chimpanzee violence actually about Warfare
in humans, I mean, can we tell anything about
whether it is really, uh, um, more of a,
let's say, a sociocultural invention or an evolved adaptation?
I mean, uh, to what extent is, or, or
to what extent can, can we derive conclusions or
information about human warfare from studying chimp violence?
Yeah, so, this is a question that has really
been at, at the heart of, of my research
for a long time now. And I think there
are Several different ways of thinking about or of
approaching the question and For some people, The, or
one way of looking at it is that if
Chimpanzees and humans both share some trait. That suggests
that that trait was present in our last common
ancestor, and maybe that trait has been around for
a long time. And so it's very intriguing from
that perspective that chimpanzees and humans make and use
tools, cooperate to hunt prey, large mammalian prey. Uh,
DEFEND group territories, live in fusion fusion societies, that
it's in both species, it's the males that do
most of the hunting and the killing and the
territory defense, and So this Suggests the possibility that
these are all part of some set of traits
that we share from our last common ancestor and
that have been present since. That last common ancestor
lived, maybe some 7 to 9 million years ago.
The Uh, the existence of bonobos and the ways
that they differ from both chimpanzees and humans. Challenges
that that idea because bonobos don't have, you know,
they, they don't do much with making and using
tools. They, they hunt monkeys, but not really cooperatively
in, in groups like chimpanzees do. Uh, THEY don't
really defend territory boundaries. Uh, THEY don't engage in.
Cooperative killing of other bonobos, uh, to a large
degree. There, there have been some interesting, uh, cases
that suggest that they, they can do that, but
they, uh They don't seem to engage in those
activities anywhere near the frequency that chimpanzees and humans
do. Uh, SO that suggests that if these traits
were present in the last common ancestor, uh. Then
Bonobos must have lost those traits for some reason,
or These traits evolved independently in humans and chimpanzees
separately for, for similar, but perhaps for similar reasons.
So people argue a lot about the. You know,
the, the evolutionary history of these traits and, and
what the relevance is. And I think implicit in
that for for many people is this idea that
The Underlying psychology of, of warfare, uh, must be
something inflexible, hard to change over evolutionary time, and
that if chimpanzees and humans both engage in this,
it's, you know, kind of part of our, this
deep nature that we can't easily change and we're,
we're kind of stuck with it. And, uh, People
who are very critical of the, the chimp violence
hypothesis like Brian Ferguson and Doug Fry and others.
I think what they're reacting, one of the things
that they are concerned about is that this view
of Warfare and violence coming from some Ancient deep
part of our psychology means that it's an intractable
problem and we uh We can't do anything to
stop war and that people will use this argument
to justify ongoing warfare and preparation for war.
Yes, that would be a form of biological determinism
or something like that,
right? Yeah, and, and it's also, you know, Kind
of an argument from phylogenetic inertia that these things
with an old evolutionary history and old phylogeny are
just going to go forward regardless of whether they're
adaptive in current circumstances or not. I think the
real value of studying ape violence is is really
more subtle than that, and the arguments that Richard
Wrangham and others have made about the relevance of
chimpanzees to understanding the origins of human warfare don't
depend on. PHYLOGENETIC continuity. They don't depend on these
traits being um present. In some unbroken history over
time, uh, that's something that, that Wrangham has often
made the argument that there, there is that deep
shared history, but the You know, the, the papers
that he's published don't insist on that point as
being the reason why these are relevant. Uh, FOR,
for example, going back to, uh, a paper with
Joe Manson, Manson and Ringham in 1991, uh, that
paper argues that the reason that chimpanzees and humans.
Kill members of rival communities. It really derives, it's,
if, if you think about why animals kill in
general, why does violence occur. From a behavioral ecology
point of view. The, the assumption is that animals
in general. Perform actions based on some kind of
cost-benefit analysis. Whether they do that in their head
or whether that's something that natural selection has figured
out over evolutionary time and Designed their bodies in
such a way that they, they respond in adaptive
ways to the circumstances that they find themselves in.
Some sort of assessment occurs, and the behavior should
evolve if, on average, it produces net benefits. And
so that suggests that for killing to occur, either
the, the benefits should be very high or the
costs should be low, relative to the, the benefits
that you gain. And the benefits that chimpanzees gain
from, from killing members of rival communities don't seem
to be unusually high compared to the benefits that
other primates gain from intergroup aggression. Uh, THEY compete
over territory, but lots of primates compete over territory
and, and don't kill each other. But What does
seem to be different is that the costs of
killing. Can be very low in the conditions, the
circumstances in which chimpanzees usually kill members of rival
communities, which is in these gang attacks on lone,
isolated individuals, and this is something that happens because
of the ecology of chimpanzees where the food supplies.
Vary a lot during the course of the year.
Sometimes food is abundant and they can travel together
in cohesive groups. Other times, food is scarce, so
they scatter. And the scarcity of food is not
uniform across a habitat like a, a forest. In
some places, there might be enough food for chimps
to stay together in larger parties. In other places,
they're forced to scatter. So the scattered chimps are
then vulnerable to Encountering a large group of males
from the neighbors who are able to stay together
for whatever reason. If they find an isolated individual,
they can gang up on and attack and kill
that individual with impunity. And uh And by, by
killing their opponent, they reduce the coalition strength of
their neighbors, and that weakens them and so that
in future territorial encounters, they, they won't be able
to push back and, and so the, the killers
can expand their range. And This is also what
we see in in humans is that In subsistence
level human societies like hunter-gatherers. People don't like to
engage in costly fights. They much prefer killing in
ambushes, sneak attacks, raids, uh, situations where they have
overwhelming numerical superiority and very little risk of being
injured in return. And So what this suggests is
that the propensity towards killing members of of rival
groups that humans and chimpanzees share. IS something that
it, it may have a common evolutionary history or
it may have evolved convergently in humans and chimpanzees.
We, we don't know the answer to that, but
the underlying Ecology Appears to be similar and Uh,
and I think that's really where, where the power
is more than in looking at this as some
kind of phylogenetic inertia argument. Instead, it's, it's looking
at this is an adaptive trait that. CAN change.
And respond to local conditions. And it is not.
Determined in a simple way by an inflexible biology,
but instead responds. Adaptively to local ecological conditions and
and social environments. And, and I think. It it's,
it's useful to think about what What would be
the case if if human societies Uh, You know,
if, if humans Chad Only cultural. Control over propensity
to engage in warfare, you know, for example, what,
what if warfare is completely a cultural invention like
Margaret Mead argues, and, and this is what people
like Douglas Fry have argued that that warfare is
something that emerged. As a cultural trait. Relatively recently
in human prehistory, with the advent of complex hunter-gatherer
societies that are more sedentary and then uh intensified
with the origin of the domestication of crops and
livestock. And What, uh, Douglas Fry and and A
number of archaeologists have argued is that, you know,
war really only appears. Around that time, in the
last 10,000 years or so, um, and is, is
a response to these changing cultural conditions. And So
Let's, let's suppose that that's the case. Let's suppose
that that warfare is entirely cultural and, and for
the sake of the argument that that warfare didn't
occur in humans before the origin of complex hunter-gatherers.
Well, What does, would that change our understanding of
Of warfare, would that change our understanding of of
what Makes people behave in warlike ways. And I'm
not really sure that it would because the We
are, we know from observing human societies that We,
we don't engage in warfare in a simple reflexive
way that You know, there's a lot of variation
in rates of war and peace around the world,
and you know, the experience of You know, Parts
of the world like Europe that, uh, you know,
went through enormous Cataclysms of world wars in the
20th century, Europeans after the war developed institutions and
frameworks that succeeded in preventing such wars for, you
know, here we are 80 years after the end
of World War II, and, and Apart from You
know, Eastern Europe, in Central Europe, Western Europe. There's
been international peace. So we know this, we, we
don't have to, you know, Imagine things about our
biology, you know, we know that there are conditions
that can lead to more peaceful international relations. So
then what are the conditions that promote that? What
are the conditions that lead to, to warfare? Um,
I think those are interesting questions and they don't
depend on. Having an assumption about warfare being either
biological or, or cultural.
Mhm. No, yeah, I, I would definitely, uh, like
to, perhaps we would have to schedule a second
interview to talk just about this topic because, uh,
I've been following the discussion for a few years.
I've had Doctor Rangam on the show, Dr. Glowacki
on the show who fall a little bit more
on the side of it being, uh, more, or
adding some biological underpinnings to. And I've also had
Doctor Douglas Fry and uh Brian Ferguson who fall
more on the side of the cultural invention sort
of approach to warfare. So I would definitely like
to talk with you more about that, but we
have just 12 more minutes. So if you don't
mind, I would like to move on to another
topic here. So, you mentioned bonobos and chimpanzees. I
would like to ask you. Of course we are
equally closely related to phylogenetically speaking to chimpanzees and
bonobos. In terms of the rates of violence, I
mean how much do they differ because for a
long time I remember hearing that bonobos were much
less violent than chimpanzees. There were even Sort of
like a hippie ape or something like that. It
was just about the sex and peace and so
on, but in more recent years, I've been hearing
people saying that perhaps some of that was overblown
or overhyped, and actually the rates of violence are
a little bit higher than people thought. So I
mean, what do we know about that actually?
Yeah, so, you know, bonobos are super interesting, and
there's a lot that I, I think as As
a field, we still don't know or understand about
bonobos. There's a lot that I don't understand about
bonobos and am uh eager to, to learn, uh.
And I think we're very lucky to have them
because they, if, if we only had chimpanzees, we,
we could tell a simple story about human evolution
that, that might be wrong, but having, having bonobos
and taking them seriously forces us to think a
little harder about these things. Uh, BUT I think
it's, it's really important to To, to do comparative
studies in a way that's careful and quantitative, where
we can really be confident in our results. And
There have been a lot of claims, you know,
for example, the claim that bonobos are such a
sexy ape. Well, OK. Um, What do you mean
by sexy? If, if you focus on the rate
of copulation between males and females, Che Hashimoto did
careful comparative work of, uh, bonobos and chimpanzees using
the same methods and found that the rate of
copulation between males and females is higher in chimpanzees
than in bonobos. Oh,
OK, so that's interesting,
yeah, um. And, you know, bonobos have more same-sex
interactions uh than chimpanzees do. Probably. I'm not, I'm
not sure that that has been really looked at
in a systematic way. Um, MAYBE it hasn't. I'm,
I'm just ignorant of those studies. Uh, BUT to
make claims about that, ideally, what you would have
is, is a careful systematic study. And In, in
our big collaborative paper from 2014 where we looked
at rates of violence across Chimpanzee and bonobo study
sites, we found lots of cases of killings by
chimpanzees across Africa, uh, regardless of our measures of
human disturbance. That didn't seem to explain rates of
killing, but we didn't have any definite cases of
killing by bonobos, uh, even though there were many
hours of observation of bonobos, uh, already by that
time. So if, if by violence, You mean Uh,
Well, if you, if you define that. Or focus
just on lethal violence, on killing. Bonobos Do seem
to kill much less often than chimpanzees. There are
some, some cases now of, of, of lethal aggression
in, in bonobos, but it's, it's rare. And So
that, but there's a difference between violence and aggression.
So aggression. You know, more, more broadly includes things
like threats and chases and, and displays, um, but
also, uh, You know, physical, you know, coming to
blows in ways that are not necessarily fatal. And
so, so, uh uh let me ask you then,
in terms of uh aggression and more specifically male
aggression, er, do we know if there are differences
in expression of male aggression between wild bonobos and
wild chimpanzees?
So this is the question that my graduate student
Mode Muino sought to answer, and she worked with
uh Martin Serbeck, uh, using data from Kokollopori, the
field site, the Bonobo field site that, that Serbeck
runs, and doing a direct, careful comparison of using
the same methods, uh. Aggression from focal follows of
individual males, uh, bonobos and chimpanzees at Gombe. And
we thought this was just going to confirm in
a simple way what we already knew that bonobos
are so peaceful and What Mode found was For
one, rates of aggression from females towards males were
much higher in bonobos than chimpanzees. Which isn't necessarily
surprising given that female bonobos are often higher ranking
than males, but it, you know, it's, it, it
kind of goes against this idea that they're just
peaceful all the time. You know, the females are
aggressive towards males at a fairly high rate, OK?
And then there's male aggression towards females. This was
higher in chimpanzees than in bonobos, but there was
a lot of overlap, much more overlap than we
expected. There were some male bonobos that were more
aggressive towards females than some male chimpanzees were, and
males that were more aggressive towards females had higher
mating success. So, so that's, that was interesting, but
the thing that really surprised us was that the
rates of aggression by males towards other males were
much higher in bonobos than chimpanzees. Mm, OK. So,
You know, that, uh, that was very surprising. Mhm.
And uh there, there's just recently been a study,
and I, I haven't uh looked at it yet.
It just came out looking at comparing rates of
aggression in captive bonobos and chimpanzees, and I, I
think they found that there was, there was no
measurable difference between them. Um, AND, you know, of
course, these things. They vary. There are different reasons
for being aggressive in captivity versus the wild, but,
you know, there, there's something, there's some interesting things
going on with, with bonobos that I don't think
we, we really understand.
OK. So, uh, I mean, since we have just
5 more minutes, let me just ask you then.
I mean, at this point in time, uh, I
mean, what can we say really about uh Rates
of violence, I mean, and if there are differences,
I, I mean, of course, you've already mentioned some
differences there when it comes to female to male
violence, male to female, male to male violence, but,
uh, I mean, when, when it comes to rates
of violence between bonobos and chimpanzees, what can we
really say at this point?
Well, it relates to something else that I, uh,
I was really struck by, uh, a study that,
that Martin Serbeck published, uh, a number of years
ago reporting that bonobos had higher rates of reproductive
inequality among males than chimpanzees, meaning that the, the
males that were successful at Fathering babies, uh. We,
you know, the, the, the alpha male had a
higher share of, of those paternities than was the
case in chimpanzees. And when that paper came out,
I thought, oh, this doesn't make any sense. I,
you know, this has got to be wrong, because
bonobos are egalitarian and they're peaceful and the males
don't have high rates of aggression towards each other
and, and so this is, uh, this can't be
right, and I, um. Ended up, uh, In contact
with, uh, with Martin over email, and we, we
agreed to, to work together to try to find
out, uh, to, you know, to do some comparative
studies of bonobos and, and chimps, and this is
what led to, to, to Mode's research looking at
aggression. Mode also, uh, Worked with, uh, with Martin's
team, uh, to look at the reproductive inequality data
and, and generally, uh, found that the initial study
that Martin published was right. It confirmed that, that
the, um, there, there's quite a bit of overlap
in it, you know, there's variation depending on the
community size and so on. But the, um, the
overall pattern seemed to be in favor of bonobos
having more inequality. Of reproduction among males than than
chimps, and I think this is related to the,
the rates of aggression, and I think it's also
related to rates of violence between groups because in
bonobos, for one. Their, their grouping patterns are more
cohesive. They, they tend to be in larger parties.
More of the community is, is together during the
day, and uh males compete in a very individualistic
way with one another for access to females that
are willing to mate. And uh so when females
are fertile males compete to have access to those
and mate with them. And in bonobos, it's very
much individualistic, so males don't have much incentive to
cooperate, whereas in chimpanzees, Male Reproductive success is Um
More evenly distributed and it also depends on on
defending a group territory, so males have an incentive
to cooperate with other males to defend that group
territory and The payoff for low ranking males seems
to be that they, they have a greater chance
of siring offspring, that they, they're not just shut
out of reproductive opportunities, and it's hard to know,
you know, the chicken and the egg question of,
you know, what's, what's the driving factor here? Uh,
BUT I, I think these things are, are intimately
related to each other. Mhm
Great, so, um, just before we go, would you
like to tell people where they can find your
work on the internet?
Yes, so I have a, a website, um, a,
a blog that's, uh, I, I probably haven't been
super active with in, in recent years, but it
does exist and, and a lot of my papers
are, are up there. It's called Monkey Business. Um,
AND I also, um, have, uh, you know, a
Google Scholar page and, uh, a, a website at
the, um, at the University of Minnesota. Uh. And
um Yeah.
OK, great. So I will be leaving links to
that in the description of the interview, and Dr.
Wilson, thank you so much for taking the time
to come on the show. It's been a fascinating
conversation.
Great. Well, thank you so much, Ricardo. It's, it's
been a pleasure, and I, if you want to
talk more about warfare, I'd be happy to. Yeah.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognun, Machael Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov, Zal
Adrian Yei Poltonin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward Hall,
Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortez or
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Junior.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers is are Webb, Jim Frank Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al
Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.